أحد الرجال الذين اعتقلوا أم
خلال هذا الانقلاب المزعوم سيدي هو بسام
عوضلة ، أحد المطلعين السابقين في الحكومة والمستشار الحالي للمملكة
العربية السعودية ،
وزار وزير الخارجية السعودي عمان
مؤخرًا وكانت هناك تقارير تفيد بأنه
كان يطلب من الأردنيين
تحرير دولارنا.  صحيح
أه أولاً لا أعرف ما الذي حدث
ولكن يمكنني أن أؤكد لكم
أن الوفد السعودي جاء إلى
الأردن لإظهار دعمه للأردن
وليس لإخراج شخص من الاحتجاز ، وهذا
بالتأكيد
هو رقم واحد رقم اثنين  كان هناك
فقط
على الشبكة وكل
ما تركه السيد للسعودية هذا ما يقوله الناس
هناك بيان صادر عن الحكومة
أه في
وقت مبكر من مساء أمس قال فيه أن
لعبة البيسبول
لا تزال محتجزة وهذه الأيام
لا يمكنك إخفاءها
إذا غادر شخص ما البلاد أو  أو بقينا
في
البلد ، نحن الآن قرية عالمية
أعني وأثق
حقًا في المجتمع الذي مرّت
به الحكومة من
قبل الدستور  إذن فماذا عن
الاقتراحات بتورط كيانات أجنبية
في هذا الانقلاب المزعوم
جيدًا وفقًا للمعلومات
التي لدي والتي تفيد
بوجود عنصر أجنبي أو
عناصر أجنبية في ذلك
، وأنا متأكد من أن
[الموسيقى]
قريبًا سنتعرف على المزيد عنها
في  هل ستنشر التفاصيل
هل يمكنكم أن تكونوا أكثر وضوحا في
المعلومات التي
لديكم حتى الآن
ما هي معلوماتي حيث
أن هناك عناصر أجنبية معينة
أرادت
استغلال الفقر والبطالة
أه الموجودة في الأردن وكل ما تعرفه كوفيت
أيضا
أتى  نحن و و و
شللوا الاقتصاد إذا جاز التعبير
، كما أدت عمليات الإغلاق إلى شل
حركة الناس ، لذلك
يبقى الناس الآن على الشبكات
ووسائل الإعلام ، لذا فهي بيئة صغيرة
مناسبة لمثل هذا الشيء
ولكن عندما أشير إلى أمة من خلال
بالاسم وقل هذه الولاية أو الدولة
لا ، ليس لدي أي معلومات
لأكون صادقًا ، لذلك لا
يمكنك أن تكون أكثر صراحة بشأن
ماهية
هذه الكيانات الأجنبية أو من هي هذه الكيانات التي أؤمن بها  هل أنت
أشعر
أنني لا أخشى شيئًا ، ولا أخشى أي شخص إذا كان لدي
اسم
سأفعله بالتأكيد أنا
فخور بأن حسين المجالي سيناتور أردني ولواء
متقاعد ووزير
داخلية سابق وكان أيضًا
قائد
الحرس الملكي في ذلك الوقت.  الملك الراحل
الحسين وشكرًا لك سيدي لانضمامك إلينا ، أثق في
أنك بخير ،
كل شيء رائع ، شكرًا جزيلاً
سيدتي ، نحن جميعًا على ما يرام ،
كلنا يد واحدة
وراء
جلالة الملك والسمو الإسرائيلي المؤتمر
لك.  لديكم خبرة واسعة في
السياسة
والمجتمع الأردني ، أود فقط أن
أبدأ بالحصول على تعليقاتكم على الأحداث الأخيرة
في بلدكم فيما يتعلق بالأمير حمزة ،
لم يتم تقديم الكثير من المعلومات
حول هذا الانقلاب المزعوم ،
ماذا يمكنك أن تخبرنا
وأين يقف التحقيق.  في الوقت الحاضر
جيدًا تنظر إليه في
مسارين منفصلين المسار الأول
يتم التعامل مع ما يخص صاحب
السمو الملكي الأمير حمزة
داخل
حدود القصر.  هي قضية عائلية ،
هذه قضية عائلية ملكية يتم
التعامل معها
بين الحدود داخل
جدران المحكمة
، ونحن كأردنيين نعتقد أن
هذا هو ما يجب أن يكون عليه ، لذلك هذا مسار واحد
والمسار الثاني يسير في المسار القانوني
مع الناس.  الذين تم
اعتقالهم وليس كل الأشخاص الذين تم
اعتقالهم مذنبون فقد تم استجوابهم
وبعد ذلك يرى النائب العام
من هو أه هناك بعض
الشبهات بالتورط في أي شيء
سيتم تحويله إلى المحكمة
ليتم التعامل معها
وبيك إنك غطيت
الشرق الأوسط
لفترة طويلة جدًا وأنت مقيم في
أه كما أقول دائمًا دون تسمية
دول ولكن في دول معينة
إذا حدث هذا
الأمر فسيتم التعامل معه بالدم لن يتم
التعامل معه.
المؤسسات الدستورية
في الأمة